Philip did really really well
throughout the interview.
He was able to make sure that he was
communicating what he was thinking
all the time.
So I never worry that he had
no idea what was going on.
He went into great depth when I asked
him a question and he was usually on
point with run times and thinking
about how much space things take up.
So the three things he did well were,
he was great at making sure was
communicating his thoughts,
being very specific about run times,
and memory space.
And I'd say the third thing that he
did really well was when needed he
put out a diagram and made sure it
was very clear what he was saying.
Things that I think he
could've done better,
where I think he needed his
testing on the first question.
The fact that he wasn't using
the syntax of a testing library would
show to an interviewer that he hasn't
written that many tests, potentially.
So using the actual syntax of Python
testing library would be one thing
that would be important.
Number two would be
making sure he has the runtimes of basic
things like using data structures.
He ended up being fine in the end and
he ended up driving the right runtime.
But making sure that's down pat
is something interviewers usually
are looking for.
And I'd say the last thing is as
a full stat candidate, companies
are usually looking for people who can
not only work in the back end which
Philip clearly shows he can do, but
also work on the front end well also.
I think at the end of the Google
question where Phillip said,
not too sure about how
the rendering works.
That would indicate that he's more
backend leaning, and a real really
really strong full stat candidate would
have been able to do that part as well.